hey you folks this is it the final day
of c2e2 it's Sunday how you guys feeling
I'm exhausted you're exhausted I'm a
little tired yeah yeah me too it's been
a long weekend but we've got a lot of
great footage and I hope you guys
enjoyed our coverage and we're gonna get
one more day of it so let's go on into
the con and get to it
everybody's Brian here again at the con
day three I got trooper Darth Maul's
stormtrooper Darth Maul now Mall last
time I saw you you were a little less
clothing more menacing you get demoted
or something or why are you in trooper
gear I'm out in the battlefield today so
they decided I had to wear armor there
any want to run want me running around
topless again well I could see how that
would be a little distracting to your
enemies now I can see that you really
you really need to take care of this you
need to get a better brush or something
because even on your helmet best I can
with what I have to work with
maybe maybe get the lightsaber in there
a little bit get some of that plaque off
we can try that it's his top secret so
don't tell anybody but I'm gonna walk
around and make little kids smile and
give out training cards and awesome I'm
at vulture for buttons just like that
one right there
well you are much more cuddly than I
expected and I'm okay with that
we are Groot hey you guys watch engines
of shield oh yeah absolutely well we're
about to go into Chloe
princesses you guys don't care
whatever they're shooting dudes here
guys I feel a little unbalanced I wish
we had like another girl that's a girl
hang on just that game Hey hi what's
your name Heather Heather hi Ariana nice
to meet you hi I saw him like hosting
this comic book show with these dudes
there's a lot of dudes do you think do
you think maybe you can help us sister
out maybe worse all right so here's what
I ask from you can you help us the show
sure why not
hey this is Heather with awesome comics
and I'm here with Batman today so Batman
how old are you seven seven wow that's
awesome is this your first time ever at
c2e2 yes I know the movie doesn't come
out until Friday but are you gonna beat
Superman in Batman vs Superman what's up
guys Ayanna here with my two new best
friends this is Ellie and this is Mia hi
and you were telling me a little bit
about your costume who made your host
you my mom your mom did that's amazing
did you help it all and Ellie has orange
ones ooh so you can match later that's
pretty cool awesome your best friends
were all best friends now and I heard a
rumor about like who your favorite
costume was who was that yeah that's
right well thanks so much ladies we're
gonna head out it was really great
meeting you have fun with your Legos
we'll talk to you later
hey Doug it's a your old pals the
awesome Comics crew I got a question for
ya
would you uh review Batman V Superman
dawn of Justice with us on Monday let me
make something perfectly clear I will
never ever ever review Batman Superman
dawn of Justice ever in my entire life
yoga all right fantastic thanks but yeah
all right okay that's awesome
comics that's gonna do it for c2e2 2016
we are gonna be on Channel awesome on
Monday March 28th that is our first
official show make sure you tune in then
we're gonna be reviewing Batman V
Superman dawn of Justice are you excited
I'm excited I just really really want a
really good DC movie it may not happen
but I just hope that it will I hope so
too
Porter I'm not excited it's gonna suck
well we're gonna find out Monday March
28th make sure you tune in until next
time let's blow up
Thank You Moll you bet Hey look for a
channel awesome able to see all that
stuff explain this to me you uploaded a
video yesterday that you shot today how
did you do that
hello yesterday